America's crime crisis somehow getting
even more disturbing with the latest
example happening in our nation's
capital an innocent woman savagely
beaten by a group of teens on a bus it's
very hard to watch look here
what's this no one tried to help her
including the bus driver according to
the victim all she was doing was trying
to stop a group of teens from swearing
around a child
oh there was things objects meant down
at me throughout the whole incident only
thing I could recall was the kids
hitting me and kicking me and I had no
defense physically I got like a little
bruise on my arm my jackets like ripped
off of me I asked several times prior to
the stop that I was getting off at to
stop the bus stop the bus stop the bus
the bus driver made no attempts to stop
the bus he didn't know local authorities
or anything to my defense and here's how
DC's Democrat mayor reacted
I imagine it's traumatizing it shouldn't
happen and that is not the any type of
crime that we want to see in our city at
any time
the losses doesn't end there
Philadelphia police attacked by a group
of ATV and dirt bike riders who hold
bricks and bottles at officers and a top
retail CEO blasting San Francisco as the
city of chaos he's closing his company's
only Bay Area storage to organize theft
rings and a lack of safety in the city
Rising crime a key issue for midterm
voters and many are asking when
Democrats are going to say enough is
enough and judge one of the things that
I learned today from Josh krashar who
was on Newsroom said that when they're
polling voters and their crime is an
issue to them it's both Republicans and
Democrats it's not a partisan issue at
all interesting well the the problem
with what what we just saw on that bus
is reminiscent of the Kitty Genovese
case uh in 1964 when a woman was being
raped and stabbed outside of an
apartment building while 38 Witnesses
and pastors by turned up their radios
and pulled down the shade when they were
interviewed afterwards a woman was was
murdered well afterwards they said well
we thought it was a husband and a wife a
girlfriend and a boyfriend as if
domestic violence is is a legitimate uh
crime to overlook but what we've got now
is a bystander effect and the Democrats
own this the Democrats own this you know
the the chaos that's been created that
Dan Henninger talked about in the Wall
Street Journal is the chaos that we have
never seen before we are now
legitimizing the criminal embolding the
criminal and denying victims their
victimhood their status their voice by
releasing these uh defendants and these
suspects without keeping them in jail
what we're saying to them is go right
ahead you can do it again there will be
no consequences and we've got now the
organized Smash and grab the organized
theft Rings virtually no one is taking a
stand because people are afraid to do so
and you know what I thought about this a
lot Dana today the idea of police
standing down police were told to stand
down during the summer 2020 that's when
it started and once the police were told
to stand down then oh everybody else is
standing down there was no benefit to
helping someone and a lot of people are
not helping because they're fearful they
know these dirtbags are getting out they
know that if they can assault the police
they're going to come back and assault
you and until we change the laws until
we make sentences stricter until we get
rid of this notion this nonsense notion
of social justice that no one's defined
for a dirt bag who doesn't deserve
social justice but criminal justice
we're going to live with this and we're
going to lose this country none of the
prosecutors that can I just say that was
fantastic oh sure yes absolutely thank
you I know Applause isn't normally done
we're used to it now yeah
well you don't want to be this is a
daily occurrence I'm going to put you in
charge of justice system
um thank you Greg none of these
prosecutors are willing to make a course
correction yeah well here's the deal
number one I don't know if that woman's
Brave or crazy I would just as soon like
go to Beirut or go somewhere where then
tell kids to stop swearing on a bus
because right now there's nothing more
frightening than a group of teens on
their own because all all standards have
been pretty much reduced because it is
the it's the broken window effect
watching it happen right we were told
that that was uh deeply racist
um the hierarchy has changed when you
look at uh elderly Asians who are being
brutalized the champions of Tolerance
went away when women were getting raped
and beaten and murdered by released
repeat offenders the feminists took a
breather and that is because they cannot
defy the religion of social justice
that's the hierarchy now it puts the
rights of criminals mostly male above
everybody else so that that's why it's
like well we really can't talk talk
about an increased police presence
because the increased police presence
it upsets the feelings of minorities
that's an argument that's why the on
college campuses why they don't have
security where they reduce security
after a rape it's because they don't
want to upset persons of color as a
persons of color might never get
attacked they would like to have a
police presence as well but it's not
just crime that's up it's weird crime
right where are the Green Goblins what
happened to them
do you guys remember who got arrested
but they're out
some might even work at Fox you don't
know we don't know but you got an ax guy
what happened to the ax guy you have a
guy that just attacked another person
with a with a sheath you don't even need
the weapon anymore you can just use
whatever the weapon comes in that was
just today
um so what's happening is as more and
more crime increases you start seeing
these wacky bizarre examples because
everything is okay now everything is
permitted and then on top of that and
everybody knows this there's something
that you can't even talk about because
uh it's not technically a crime the
ongoing public harassment is off the
charts if it's not happening to you you
see it happen you have a completely
unstable deranged mad man you know
harassing like tourists or something and
everybody just goes like this because
they go like what am I gonna do I can't
call the cops and if the cops cops come
this guy's already gone that's happened
to me a couple of times I like looking
at what can I do you know and it's like
and that is off it's like there's a bat
signal now that goes off and tells all
the deranged that you got a free swing
because that's what's happening in the
city right now the kids were the teens
were doing that to that woman but Jesse
the bus driver had uh Ted Williams said
that the bus driver has an option to
press a button that would immediately
call for a cops to get them and to help
her and that didn't happen the adults
aren't even doing anything it's a city
bus it's probably broken it's probably
been broken for a month and no one ever
called it in this is what happens when
Society tells women to be men and men to
be women or the women fight and the guys
sit back and watch years ago this never
would have happened I never remember
seeing gangs of girls beat the hell out
of another woman while men sat around
and watched men have been told they're
toxic and women have been told they can
be even more aggressive than men and
that's what happens this is what you see
now and about the criminals the streets
will do whatever they can get away with
if the streets are going to put push and
push and the police are not going to
push back they're going to do what
they're going to do and all of these
things are the outcomes of when the
elect attacks the pillars of society
when they attack gender when they attack
law when they attack order and the
Republicans have to get a lot more
aggressive and say what is the
government doing that's working they're
not protecting your safety they're not
protecting your business they're not
protecting the Border what exactly are
you delivering on because we want to
have that debate and make the Democrats
defend the outcomes because they can't
do that there's a story in San Francisco
the city of San Francisco spent 1.7
million dollars to build a bathroom
single stall it wasn't a golden toilet
seat like Saddam Hussein metal seat 1.7
now I know how much to build a single
stall bathroom cost it's about twenty
thousand dollars maybe 25 if you use the
union guys so they're stealing the money
contractors are stealing taxpayer money
from the government and the government's
not doing anything about it because
we're not doing anything about it and
it's time we start doing something about
this here's when you return to America
uh after being away back in England for
a while you come back here do you think
we have absolutely lost it well I spent
a lot of time in New York but also I've
got a place in California in Beverly
Hills there used to be very safe I mean
you felt very safe in Beverly Hills and
very privileged to be there it feels
dangerous now I mean I I got a little
Italian in the middle of Beverly Hills
with my family normally the first night
we get in both times we've been recently
there's been a shootout in that Berry
Street and I'm like Beverly Hills
shootouts and then you hear the other
day that I'm not far from our place a
woman just completely random woman
walking along stabbed in the head with
Scissors by a maniac they kind of
attacker you're talking about and it's
it's actually unsettling and I feel it
in New York as well it just feels like
the temperature's Rising the more crazy
people around doing crazy things and
that there's a really disproportionate
attention should being paid to the wrong
people claiming to be victims there will
be people watching that video incredibly
we wouldn't be but they'll be watching
that video thinking let's poor kids you
know they've obviously had traumatic
upbrings to behave like this in other
words immediately wanting to position
them as the victims not the woman who's
being attacked by these unbearable
violent little brats and completely
disrespectful little brats not only with
the language they're using but the way
they treat that woman and until
societies and we're the same in the UK
by the way until you get back to
actually treating victims as victims and
the criminals as criminals and that's
why I applauded your speech until you do
that Society gets ever more dangerous
and ever more fractured and it is really
incumbent I think on leaders to say this
cannot be tolerated and you've got to
get back to treating victims as victims
and criminals as criminals everybody's a
victim now right everybody it's a victim
so that yeah so it's actually me the
actual victim seem less relevant yeah
it's like it's like shouting racism you
know it's like that's reduced the actual
importance of what racism is yeah hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else